so Chris our producer James handed us an
article right before we went on the air
from CNN a fairly short article course
CNN Money is closed up so this is CNN
what's left to CNN money really is what
it is it's their business section
Americans are so nervous about the state
of the economy that they're stashing
cash in the bank at a rate not seen
since the first year of Ronald Reagan's
presidency the United States government
Bureau of Economic Analysis reported
Thursday that the savings rate searched
a 13.1 percent in March up from 8
percent in February that's the highest
savings rate since November of 1981
Americans set aside and savings two
point one seven trillion dollars last
month Wow
I mean Dave when you when you hear that
what what that screams is the unknown
you've got the fear about the virus but
people understanding the importance of
setting on some cash to take care of
yourself and your family yeah you know
we've taught for years in Financial
Peace University and then we get
criticized for that that savings is not
a mathematical problem savings is an
emotional problem you have enough money
to save money and always use the McCobb
example if your child were ill and you
had to purchase a vaccine and they said
nothing to the Cova this is 15 years ago
I used the example in videos you can go
back and look them up if you had to buy
a vaccine for ten thousand dollars
to save the life of your child you would
find a way to save ten thousand dollars
yes you would and it wouldn't be the
math you know your job didn't change you
know the math didn't change you might
pick up extra work you might hear you
but basically you would cut cable you
would cut some stuff because savings
just became very important yeah and
until it's important you won't freaking
do it generosity until it becomes
important you won't do it no there's
always a prom dress to be bought there's
always a better car a better couch
there's always a weekend trip getaway
there
always one more golf club there's always
something to freaking buy but when it
matters it has nothing to do with math
and then we get I you know you see the
stupid stuff on social media mainly from
left wing nuts that you know ramsey
hogan that bunch over there they don't
get it cuz you can't save money you
stupid people unless you have more
unless you make more money because a
person like me can't save money well by
god you are too now yeah they are and
i'm gonna tell you right now need
outweighs opinion all day every day
oh that's tweetable it is i'm a tweeter
Dave don't you do it
I don't tweet and say you said it
alright thank you but it just shows
what's possible and I think I applaud
people that are doing this I think yeah
more importantly what you need to do is
understand the plan in the process Dave
so many people have been letting money
run them and it's possible to take
control you just need the right plan but
I mean you have an oh crap moment
yeah oh crap I'm I've lost my job might
lose my job or the economy is tanking oh
crap I can't get my haircut oh crap
everything's turned upside down and
disrupted I better save some money and
maybe at a lower income than you had two
months ago you find a way to save money
yes there's a learning there for you if
that's you yeah the point is you don't
ever have to go back you can always find
money to save and invest it's a matter
of trading it for something else and
that something else is in America is
almost always lifestyle mmm no you're
absolutely right they we're a click away
from boxes showing up on our porch and
unfortunately people have been clicking
their selves right down into the poverty
line and it's time to wake up and you
hit on it this was a few weeks ago right
in the middle of the kovat thing you
said when people get serious they'll get
to that point and they'll say never
again yep and I think that's that rally
cry and one of my friends from Kentucky
I talked to him he said never again will
I put myself and my family in this
situation I'm not gonna be here ever
again that's right and so does it
happens to you in an individual a
catastrophe real you go through um you
know a loss of a job or the death of a
loved one or something and you go I'm
not gonna be I'm never gonna be broke
when this comes up again never
again we threw it when I went broke with
my 20s and I had to start over oh never
again his American Express gonna call my
house unless it's the wrong number
never again never again because I won't
be doing business with him never again
is a collector going to call never again
am I going to be without money to pay
the lights and water never again am I
gonna be without money to put food on
the table and I got babies scared me to
death man I couldn't breathe I remember
it now and it was 30 years ago almost 40
years ago and man it scares the crap out
of you
and some of you had the crap scared out
of you and you know what I I'm sorry
you're going through that but it might
be the best thing that ever happened to
you I can say for me it was the best
thing that ever happened to me horrible
I went through bankruptcy I lost
everything that gun near lost my
marriage our lights and water got cut
off because we weren't paying the bill
we were you know roof is leaking I
couldn't afford to fix it we're driving
a couple of hoop Dees I mean and and you
know but what I got out of it was a
whole lot better than the pain and what
I got out of it was a thorough never
again moment and I think a lot of people
out there right now are having that and
that's what this is driving the savings
right and people wonder why you're so
passionate people wonder why you have
such a desire to let people out there
know that it can get better and it's
because you've walked through some stuff
I mean everybody has man was just
freaking dramatic cuz I do everything
drama wise but drama queen but you know
it's still that the thing is the
takeaway for you is you can save money
yeah don't ever tell me again that you
can't save money when you need to
because two point one seven trillion
dollars went into savings in America in
one month
Wow what if generosity did that in one
month hmm what would happen what could
you do well let me Hospital me st.
Jude's hospitals could you build and
fund how many you know how much domestic
hunger could you wipe out though if you
did that so I mean and let me just tell
you the all you're doing with generosity
and savings under the heading of savings
is investing all you're doing there is
you're making a choice to not do
something because that thing
is more important Gus giving is more
important or saving investing is more
important than the purchase of a thingy
because there's always a freaking thingy
in America that you can buy it's nonstop
Dave the commercials make you feel bad
about something you don't have stayed in
a hotel a day and they gave us a
selection of pillows you've got to
select the type of pillow that you want
it this is how are you serious this is
how it was wonderful what a luxury but
how what if you're staying in a hotel
where there's a selection of pillows and
you know any money in savings we might
question your sanity on that go home you
don't need to have a selection of
pillows at the hotel and there's no
emergency okay this you might have lost
it
this is unbelievable yeah this is
wonderful news I hope that it stretches
some of the people that did this so far
they'll never return to the same shape
and that's my prediction now's the time
people never again this is the Dave
Ramsey show
[Music]